Hey, hey, hey you guys, hey, hey! Hey you know what? That reminds me. We don't have, we have a bye but we don't really have a hi. Well, why don't we do a hi. Should we start doing that? Hello! You need an opening.
Hello! We should start doing that. Because I'm like hello, have you seen the prices!? Hello! I can hear the listeners. Welcome to Smart List. Smart. Last.
Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god.
I was like... Most meek laugh you can do, Will. Go ahead. Okay, Sean, meek laugh. I can't just blow your nose. We're recording. Talk about, wait, I didn't say do the most meek nose blowing you can do. You nailed it.
I sneezed right before I came out. But how about every time you have a slight cough or sneeze? How about every time you sneeze in public? Now, anybody who I'm next to, they look at you like, what's your problem? Why are you even out of the house? I'm like, well, it's just- People, they look at you like you're a war criminal.
I know. You're like, what the fuck? But I guess I'm guilty of that too. I know. If somebody coughs more than once, right? If they cough twice, I'm like, I give them, I try to get eye contact with them like, are you okay? Or is this something I need to worry about?
Or- I still get surprised at the people who cough and don't, especially after everything we've been through, who still just cover your mouth. That's all I ask. Yeah, or just into the shirt. I used to think into the shirt was super gross, but you know what?
It's a nice gesture. It'll leave a spot, but it's better than getting someone sick. Well, it depends on the shirt, right? And the blood content in your cough. I mean, what do you mean a spot? I had a friend over last night that he was waiting. He was like congested and I'm like, why did you come over?
He's like, I'm not sick. I'm not sick. Yeah. And look, you woke up blowing your nose. Well, I just had a sneeze. Was it at least worth it, Sean? You old war horse. What was his name?
Scotty was out. That's stupid. What a dumb. We missed you all weekend, Sean. I know. Did you go Sunday? Yeah, we went Sunday. I didn't go Sunday because granddad pulled his back.
He pulled his back. Everybody was calling into question whether everybody kept going. Yeah, just pulled his back like, eh. No, it's not great. I was, I'm ashamed to say it is a golf injury. I was simply leaning over to address the ball about to swing, not even swinging.
And it just slid out. Yeah. Oh yeah, yeah. That's painful. But then Dionne Fanouf, our incredible friend. We love Dionne Fanouf. For NHL star gave me some of his CBD cream. I use that.
Let's plug it right now. It's a canny, right? Canny, canny ease or canny something? Get it right. Because you're now your fucking deans. Canny 1200. I think it's called canny golf. Can I, can I 1200?
Can he not pull his back out over 50? I mean. I'm going to get the right word there, the right title. And we're going to plug it properly. I mean, do you think the fact that you were just addressing the ball, obviously you're brittle and you have no nutrients in your body. Do you think that that is of concern to you?
Are you worried about snapping some of your limbs at any point? Because I mean, you have, you have, there's literally nothing holding you together anymore, right? It's not true. I wish I was as thin as you think I am. Or at least as thin as I should be
for the lack of food. Sean, do you remember this? About a year ago, we were playing with Chuck Day and Mack Laney and those guys up there in the valley. And we sit, there's a guy on this other, on this other hole. I don't know, maybe 92, 93. And he was just, God bless him.
He's making his way around this guy, this old, old timer. And he shuffled up to the ball and he was leaning over and I just look over and I point and Jason just goes, that's not me, motherfucker. I go, yeah, it is, that's you. I would have thought it was you for a second. That's you now.
That's you now. Jason, you are so thin. What are you talking about? I am so not, what are you talking about? I'm sorry, but I see you. I'm sorry, but I see you. 70 pounds. You're very thin.
Yeah. No, I just don't have any muscle mass because I'm not out there. Okay. Blastin' backs and buys on Tuesdays and Thursdays. Push and wait, you fucking jargon. Why don't you? Oh yeah, lifting weight, yeah, moving weight.
There's no science that says it's good for you as you get old. Oh, hang on a second. Look it up. Yeah, you're right. By the way, here's an update on the sweaters. I talked to Alex. Wait, we're moving on to sweaters?
Well, remember we talked about my mom knitting sweaters for you guys? Oh yeah. And so I guess she heard- How does that get to do with pushing weight? I'm just talking about getting older because you'll hear why. And she says, okay, well, listen,
she texted me out of the blue as she does, just apropos of nothing. I'm gonna need sizes and I'm gonna guess that Shawn is a little slimmer than Jason. Oh God, no. She just mixed up the names. That's all. That's all.
No, that's all. Like Shawn looks slimmer and you're right. I mean, you are, and I will go on record saying you're very skinny and stuff, but you just, you're never gonna lose that look. You have the look. Yeah. Yeah.
You're so right. That's the problem. I wasn't born with a beautifully angled face like you with great bone structure and a strong superhero chin. I am doughy. I am round. I am, I came out puffy. Okay.
No, you didn't. You didn't. You both have chiseled, good-looking faces. You don't. Damn, on camera, John. By the way, you want to talk about a chiseled, good-looking face? Here we go.
Uh-oh. This is the segue of All Segway. Beautiful. Let me tell you something, guest. You better not look puffy after that intro. Check your lighting right now. Don't worry. He won't.
I've never seen him look puffy and I've never seen him look bad. It's impossible for him. And he is, just, and he's maintained it for so long, which is really admirable. On top of which, the really most admirable thing about him is that how well he's maintained a career that has spanned decades.
For decades, this guy has been at the top of the list. It is unbelievable. Willem de Beau. We knew when we were kids. We were talking about an angular face. Again, again, we know him. So I can't, I gotta be really careful because I just want to get a little bit out before
you guys start. Before you start guessing, you don't know Robert Pattinson and he doesn't want to know you. It's a triangular face. I know, but he has no interest in seeing you. But this guy, even Robert Pattinson looks up to this guy. Willem de Beau.
This guy has done everything. He's done every, the top of the game in film and television. He's done some of the most iconic films, some of the most iconic television. He's been nominated for two Emmys, six Golden Globes, four SAG awards, which he's won two. He's starred in so many 80s classics. He was part of what was then known as the Brat Pack.
He's been in same almost bars about last night. The Outsiders, West Wing, Parks and Recreation. It's our friend, Mr. Robert Lowe. Now that is a beautiful man. Wait a minute. Why are you on set right now? He's in a cop uniform. He's got a cop uniform on.
Yeah. It's a fireman's uniform. Yes. A fireman. A fireman, sorry. I told the whole crew. I said, I got to go see my boys. I got to go see my guys.
This is so lovely. He's on the set of 9-1-1 Lone Star, which is the show that he stars in. And he produces in your fourth season, you're shooting your fifth season maybe? We are almost done with season four. Almost done with season four, unbelievable. I see clips of that show and I'm tired looking at like,
I guess it looks like watching our whole episode. You rude bastard. What? Try watching a full episode, not the clips. Yeah, watch the episodes. Don't watch the clips. The clips don't help. No, no, like the promos.
I mean, the promos. And I see your face and I'm like, God, Rob just finished a 15 hour day on that episode. Like, it's just looks so like sun's work. Do you sleep in olive oil, Rob? Is there a mattress that's got a zip-in olive oil pouch that you sleep in? I know, look at the best skin in the world.
I'm an Olympic sleeper. I think that we've talked about, I get a lot of sleep. I mean, I have shame around how much I sleep. Because it makes me seem like- So you still sleep like you're a teenager? Yes. How many hours is that? What time are you in the rack every night, Rob?
Well, today I had to be in the car at 5.15 in the morning. Now, but as you know, I live in Santa Barbara and I'm lucky enough to be driven so I can sleep in the car. So I get an extra hour and a half in the car, but I was in bed at 9.30 last night. Okay. And then you're up it.
So what time are you getting up for a 5.15, getting the car? 5.14. Truly. 5.14, because I don't really wanna- Now you're gonna get my typical morning questions now and I'm gonna try to keep this clean. But hang on now, why are you leaving the house without a shower or without emptying yourself?
You're doing that in your trailer? All of that? I don't do the morning shower. I do the nighttime shower. Nice. Yeah, I get that. I do the nighttime shower. So then what do you do about your bed head then?
You let the people in the makeup hair trailer do that? That's what the professionals are for. Isn't it nice if you can- Hold it, Sean. You could save yourself an hour if you don't do makeup and you do your own hair before you leave the house. How does it save me an hour?
That costs me an hour. That means I have to wake up earlier. Yeah, that's true. God, that's great math. God, I'm sorry. Isn't it nice to take a shower at night? Yeah. It makes you feel like a kid.
I sometimes take a shower, put my pajamas on, watch TV and then you go straight to bed. Brush your teeth and go to bed. Oh, yeah. Now I look forward to going to sleep. I'm like, I'm gonna go to bed. I do love that. Yeah.
Now, Rob, you're an incredibly talented actor. You can't get this far without being a really good actor. Did it ever bother you that like, it seems like the only people that get real good accolades as an actor are those that look like character actors. You don't. You look like a leading man.
Was it ever frustrating to you that you didn't get the character roles because you were born with leading man looks? Well, first of all, thank you for saying that. And I do feel like I'm a character actor trapped in a leading man's body. Well, look at Austin Powers. You are hysterical in Austin Powers.
Well, thank you. It's a long list. And when I get to, you know, Johnny Depp's made a career of not, you know, he's so handsome, but he wears prosthetics and stuff. And so he gets to do these insane characters. And every time I've been able to do that, I've found it very freeing.
But, yeah. Let's talk about that. Because your trajectory has been, it's so hard. I mean, everybody's got their own sort of path that they have, but yours has gone through so many different areas. And I was, a lot of people have peaks and valleys. You haven't even had any valleys.
It's been sort of like from peak to peak. And you've just kind of jumped. You started in, and I mentioned sort of the Brad Pack, but you started in, was the Outsiders your first big film? Was my first movie period. I mean, I... Okay, so talk about that. Talk about that process.
How you got it and how it came about and what it was like. I mean, Jesus. I wish you guys had been, in that mix, you would have, it was an incredible thing. And all of us who went through it are bonded, we're like band of brothers, because Coppola put us through such an arduous, insane. And I think actually illegal Screen Actors Guildwise
type of boot camp. Really? Went on for months, months and months and months, mixing and matching. And you'd go into this sound stage and there'd be like Mickey Rourke with roller skates on, stinking like an animal. And being treated like he was the Marlon Brando reincarnated.
And then you'd have Scott Baio coming in in a limousine and telling Francis he had to get back to a show. And Francis going, what show? And he goes, happy days. And Francis going, what's that? Oh my God. And then you'd have like Ricky Schroeder and Dennis Quaid and I mean, just anybody and everybody.
So he was doing like mixing and matching or were these like kind of forced bonding kind of chemistry reads? The forced bonding came later, but these were mix and matches with everybody present. So everybody showed up at eight o'clock in the morning and you left at seven o'clock at night and you just sat on the floor and he would go,
okay, I wanna see Dennis Quaid with Henry Thomas and Ricky Schroeder and whatever. Wow, that's wild. Wow. What was the name of your character again? It wasn't- Soda Pop. Soda Pop.
Yes. Soda Pop. You know what's really cool about the Outsiders is every, it's part of the seventh grade curriculum. Yeah. Of almost every school in the country. So every year there's a new group of seventh graders who get introduced to not only to the Outsiders,
but the, you know, like, Soda Pop, Curtis, yay. So that's super cool. And look at you now from Soda Pop to cop. I literally just had a guy send me a text this morning and he said, stay gold pony boy. He literally said that on a text this morning from Harry Chung, Will. Oh yeah?
Yeah. I remember when I was in the movie, I was about to lay in whoever did it, but I like Harry a lot. He's a friend. Harry's a good man. He's a good man. So-
I remember when you were in contact. I remember when you were in contact and it was like, that's one of my favorite movies of all time. Yeah, I love it. And I was like, and you showed up on screen. I was like, wait, that's Rob Lowe. I was like, I don't know, 22 years old when it came out, I was like, wait, Rob Lowe is in this movie.
That's so crazy and amazing. Like, to Will's point, you would take no peaks, just all peaks, right? No valleys. And you would appear even if it was the smallest role or a leading role or whatever. There were always seams at least the perception was that they were all super high quality movies and TV shows.
Totally. And by the way, sometimes with Sean Robb, as you know, sometimes it's like having a kid come in because it just goes, I remember when you were in contact and you're like, okay, man, we're not just fucking doing free form, just whatever pops into our fucking head.
Jesus Christ. I remember one time I saw you on a fucking what, man? Jesus. I remember. I thought you had a billboard one. It's nominated for his question asking skills. Of the three of us, he was nominated for the host of the year. Singled out.
But Rob, Rob, you don't get to singled out. Singled out of the trifecta. No, is this true? This is amazing. No, yeah. It's true. It's 100% true. The best host of a podcast.
Well, there's three of us, you know? No, just Sean. Just Sean. That is the greatest thing I've ever heard. Yeah. He didn't win, okay? That's the greatest thing I've ever heard. Why?
Missed it. Because they finally went and listened to it. And then they were like, oh, shit. Not him. But Rob, so you do like the outsiders, and it is true as Sean says, and what we were saying, which is like, you do all these things that are amazing,
that each one of them have a place in, culturally, a place in everybody's lives, whether it's the outsiders, and then saying almost fire about us. Which I just saw. I just watched it for the first time ever. Are you serious? I swear to God.
Never saw it. I watched it like a month or two ago. No, he's saying, are you serious that you're just interrupting and giving us an alert? Sorry. So you do the outsiders. What was film number two? After the outsiders, which was a big sensation,
and we all saw it, what was the next thing? What was the move when that came out? Was it like you had everything offered to you? All of us got a lot of offers. I mean, I think Tom did the best with it because he followed it up with Risky Business, and that was the beginning for him. I did a movie called Class with Andrew McCarthy
and Jacqueline Bassett. Yes, you did. Oh, I know it well. Good for you, Rob. Right? Yeah, great film. Good for you, okay? Class act.
Right? What was going on there? Okay, go ahead. No. No. Yeah, no. You don't have to admit to anything on this podcast. You just keep going with your answer.
I thought. Wait, I have something I want to say about contact after Will gets there. Holy fuck. I love that he's obsessed with contact. I had two lines in it, but it's good movie. I'm obsessed with you in it too. Obsessed, Will.
I used it. Obsessed, and it's his favorite movie of all time. Go figure it. Hey, listen, Rob, so you do, oh god. Thanks to Star Trek. Sometimes it's like, you just got to breathe. They're right. You just do have to breathe.
Finish your juice box, Sean. So, Rob, so you do class with Andy McCarthy. Jacqueline Bassette, yep. Jacqueline Bassette, and then what was after? Then it's Sean's favorite actor, Jody Foster. Yes. Can I say something about that movie? In Hotel New Hampshire, and Hotel New Hampshire was gonna be,
that was the one everybody, all the young actors wanted to do, because they thought it was gonna be Oscar type movie, because in those days, however you want to call them, Bratback movies, Teen movies, John Hughes movies, whatever you want to call them, they were like the guilty pleasure of the movie business. Like today they'd be straight movies.
There'd be no guilt associated with them at all. In fact, they'd be the tent pole. But in those days, it was like, in terms of endearments, the real movie this year, okay? And, oh, you're doing that trifle over here? Like that's the way it was, that's what it was. It was very segregated in that way, but Hotel New Hampshire felt like a real movie.
Of course, then it came out the same weekend as Splash, and that was the end of it. Oh, wow. Wasn't that a John Irving book? It's a John Irving book, yeah, yeah. And it did, I remember when that came out, God, what was that like? There he goes.
85? 84, 83, 83, late 83. So, I know I messed up on that one. I'm usually a really good movie. But just inside the same decade was just incredible. That, but so you do, but you did, I know that you're sort of, you're saying that these are the films that were the trifle,
but these were the films that people were going to see, that all of us were going to see. You know, I mean, I wasn't a huge student of the cinema yet. And those are the movies that I wanted to go see. I wanted to go see you guys in those. I wanted to go see Youngblood, by the way, as a Canadian. Yeah, yeah. Dude, Rob, let's talk about Youngblood for a second.
Youngblood, I mean, on Quick Five for us? Sure. Yeah, go ahead, Rob, talk about it. Yeah, go ahead. Youngblood is, I think it might be the second best hockey movie at first is Slap Shot. Let's face it, Slap Shot's one of the greatest movies ever made, period.
Mighty Ducks, Mighty Ducks, Mighty Ducks. No, I'm throwing down. I'm sorry, I'm not having it. No, I mean, I'm just not having it. I know, I'm with Rob, I'm with Rob. Now, yeah, Youngblood is fun, because whenever I get to go to a hockey game, people are super excited,
because there aren't that many hockey movies. There aren't that many, if you're a hockey fan, there aren't all that many, really. No, dude, and we loved, as a Canadian, we loved Youngblood, and I would say this, Slap Shot maybe because it came before in Paul Newman, et cetera, but they're kind of different. They fall into different categories within hockey.
So it's in terms of like a pure hockey movie that's not a comedy, Youngblood is the best in that regard. So they're very different. Pure hockey, pretty few young hockey player. I mean, everybody who's played hockey has worn that movie out, because it's about coming up into the league, so. Now, were you a good skater?
Were you playing hockey at that time? No. That was horrible. I mean, I could Rockefeller Center date, hold hands, skate. Right. And so it was the first time I ever had a trainer or I had to work at, and I,
Swayze was my co-star, Patrick Swayze, and we trained every day for almost eight weeks, six hours a day. Brutal, brutal, brutal training, and I got to be pretty good on skates at that point. Wow, and Keanu was in it too. No, what? He was the goalie.
He was the goalie. I thought he was an actual French-Canadian goalie. He was, right? We had him on the podcast. We just had him on the podcast. We didn't say that he was a goalie. He was a goalie, yeah. Yeah.
There you go. Someone listens. Do you remember interacting with Keanu back then and thinking like, oh, this kid's gonna do something? Like, do you have anything like that? Will, I'm telling you, and this is no slight to Keanu Reeves who I adore, I thought he was a French-Canadian goalie.
Wow. I thought, which probably tells you all you need to know because I thought he was the real thing. That's how good he is. And we will be right back. Listeners, this episode is brought to you in part by Benjamin Moore. Now, I live in a home.
I have other people that live in the home with me, my wife and my two children. And what you gotta do when you are alive is eat. And someone's got to cook, and I'm the only one that raises their hand every once in a while, but I should keep it down because the cooking is terrible. What happens with the cooking
is that the cooking ends up getting thrown across the room and onto the wall. So what I need is a lot of white paint around. And I like to use Benjamin Moore because that's high quality white paint. You're not gonna see the pasta sauce bleed through, okay, I have issues. And so I need high quality paint, right?
Got it? We all love a beautiful home, but messes are a part of home life, especially my home life. So it's great having a high quality paint to stand up to everything from my bad cooking to kids and dogs and everything in between. Gang with Benjamin Moore's premium colors,
you can see the difference. They have a whole team dedicated to ensuring best in class formulations that are better, stronger and simpler. Benjamin Moore paint is only sold at locally owned stores. Say 15% off your next paint or sample purchase at benjaminmoore.com using code SMARTLESS. That's benjaminmoore.com, code SMARTLESS.
Now there are some great things about being an adult. Am I right? Like you can have ice cream for dinner the whole week off if you really want to. Two different colored socks, just go ahead and get crazy. But then there's the other side of it, you know, adulting and the actual responsibilities that come with it, working, paying bills,
buying a home, the big stuff. There's no instruction manual for any of it. So figuring it out on your own, well, it can be stressful. Am I right, fellow adults? With State Farm, you can scratch insurance off that list. So when you ask yourself, what if my policy doesn't cover this or what if I have to make a claim in the middle of the night
or even what if I don't know what something in my policy means? State Farm is there for your what ifs. You can file a claim on the State Farm mobile app, talk to a real person, including your agent, and you can call day or night about insurance coverage and policy questions because that's just what they do. It's what they do there at State Farm. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there.
Call or go to statefarm.com for a quote today. You're welcome. Hey, smart list listener. Did you know that we get support from Helix? Well, you do now. You know what else Helix supports? My napping addiction. So with this Helix mattress that I got,
I got the Midnight Luxe mattress, so do Will Arnett. He also likes napping. I have found this is the best mattress for sleeping while the sun is up. And if you're a loser like me that can pack a lot of sleep in during work hours, let me tell you something. The Midnight Luxe will keep you unemployed as long as you want.
Now that's about as great an endorsement as I can give, folks. The Helix lineup includes 14 unique mattresses, including a collection of luxury models, a mattress for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for the night. And even a mattress made just for kids. I'm imagining that smaller.
There are models with memory foam layers to provide optimal pressure relief if you sleep on your side, or models with a more responsive foam to cradle your body for essential support in stomach and back sleeping positions. Helix has been awarded the number one mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine.
Not sure what makes them experts on sleeping, but they are reputable publications and I am taking it as a positive. It's even recommended by multiple leading chiropractors and doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to solution for improving your sleep. On top of all that, you've got my personal endorsement
for how it can keep you napping while everyone else is working. Helix is offering up to 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With Helix, better sleep starts now. And now back to the show.
Well, on the same sort of question on outsiders, was it clear to you, or if you had to bet on one of those horses to have the kind of longevity that you ended up having in your career, who'd you think was gonna be with you? Tony Boyd would be the horse I bet on. Tony Boyd is the horse I bet on.
I mean, yeah. I mean, again, and it's funny because Tom has obviously become, you know, a legendary, legendary actor. And I'm not sure you would have back in the day, but he had such drive, such, he had an intensity that none of us have. And then Taps, I think, put him over the top, right?
Or was it? Taps was right before. Taps was before. Taps was, come on. Taps had made him, yeah. And he was so good in that move. I got it. Taps was my first Hollywood, big Hollywood premiere. That was, I remember that movie really knocking me out.
Yeah. Wait, can we go, like, go back to the beginning? Go back to contact, sure. And so on, on contact. What was Tony? No, I want it. Did it say, were you scared? Did you think the aliens were really coming? He's all hopped up on apple juice now.
Go, let him go. Do it. Well, no, well, since you brought it up at the content, but I want to know, I want to go back. Yep. Before the outsiders, but I just want to get this out about contact. My favorite line in the movie is just.
You are the worst. Go ahead. Only person I know I get drunk on apple juice. Just swerving all over the podcast. I am dying. I can't pull over and take a nap. I can't believe you're torturing Rob like this. I want to get out my favorite line in contact,
which was Jodi Foster and Matthew McConnay. Well, McConnay was in it. Yeah, Jodi Foster and Matthew McConnay. And I think it's like the second time they kiss in the movie. And Jodi pulls away and she's, and her first line, I'm not making this up, is I'm so confused. And that's your favorite.
I'm gonna go to your nomination for this year. So no, Jodi Foster's a friend and she would laugh at that. So. Fuck me. I want to go back. You're literally crying. Will is literally crying, tears of laughter. Hey Rob, you've got your own podcast.
You can see, it's not easy, right? It's not easy at all. You got to deal with. Fuck you. This is why I do mine alone. Exactly, if you deal with the nonsense. Thank you. No, I love you so much.
I love you too so much. So, Rob, before the outsiders, we kind of just skipped over, like I don't know anything about your like pastor. You're like, how did you get that? I'd like, wasn't that such a huge deal? What were you doing before that? Like theater or anything?
I was doing theater when I lived in Ohio. My family lived there. I was eight years old. And I went and saw a local school production and fell in love with the kid. Like, you know, like I was like, I want to do that. And my parents were like, yeah, sure, whatever. So you had a love for it when you were super young?
Super young. It's all I ever knew exactly what I wanted to do. Wow, isn't that wild? But you couldn't pursue it in Ohio, right? Was there a move out to Los Angeles that triggered like, okay, I want to, I actually want to do this now. Well, my thing was I'm going to do, I did every sort of university.
There was a traveling, oh God, this thing called the Kenley Players. You got to look this up guys. It's the best. We should make a movie about this. The Kenley Players. It would be summer, professional summers. It's like waiting for Guthman, but real.
John Kenley was a musical theater producer, lived as a woman in Florida during part of the year. And then was John Kenley in the Midwest. And of course the Midwestern people were never the wiser. And he would get whoever's the hottest TV star and put them in Camelot or something like that. And then they would tour Dayton, Cincinnati, Akron, Columbus, Flint, Michigan.
And you'd like, Henry Winkler would come in and just crush for four weeks in the summer. And you'd see like Vic Tabak in Manila Mancha. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Or, and it was the most delicious. Sandy Duncan is Peter Pan. Of course, yes, hot. Jason's old co-star.
Uh-huh. Oh yeah. Wait, so Rob, but that's a good point. So you're doing this thing, this touring theater thing, which it does sound amazing. And then what? What do I say in my Paul Lynn stories? Well, fucking let's go. Yeah. Look at you, you little jubblet.
Oh, that actually sounded more like Charles Nelson Riley. No, a mix of the two. This is definitely a mix of the two. One of my favorite Paul Lynn lines on Hollywood Squares was the host said, okay, for the center square, for the X, Paul, when a man falls over a boat, you yell man overboard. What do you yell when a woman falls over a boat?
And he goes, false bait ahead. Wait, wait, how did you, where did you encounter Paul Lynn? First of all, Rob. Oh, the Kenley players. Not on Hollywood Square. Did you ever do Hollywood Squares? No, I did the 10,000, this is how long it was,
how long ago it was, the $10,000 pyramid. Oh wow. Before it was 25 or 100. Yes, with Dick Clark. And that was a, that was my first trip to New York, publicity trip, and I played against Tony Danza and I eviscerated him. I once took Tony Danza deep at the Hollywood Stars night.
Wow, no way. Yeah, he threw a little cookie over the plate and I took it out to right center field. I love that. Yep, past the sprinting Luforigno, inside the park home run. Then they, what, you went around the bases on a gurney or what, you probably pulled something for sure.
At that time, I was pretty limber. You really were not 18. I love those old, the old time Dodger Hollywood stars. The first one I played in, it was such a huge thrill, it was 1979. And I stepped up to the plate and they were, now batting, Rob, load. No way.
No way. And it was amazing. And I think I might have got a fielders choice to first base or whatever. And I was like, super, because in those days it was super competitive actually. And then at a certain point it devolved into hijinks and then you'd get Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
pitching to Billy Barty. Right, with a huge, with a large bat. With a huge bat. That's right, yes. And that's what happened and then it all, but it was, that was my moment at the Hollywood stars. I talk to Kimmel about this sometimes, like we should approach them and ask them
if they would be interested in us just sort of just like, let's make this thing overhand again, fast pitch, baseball, because like now I think it's like softball, they bring in a fence and we should get it back too. Listen, I'm gonna make that, if you're down. And Jason's like, how can we set the fun back out of it? You know what I mean?
Do you ever hear, Rob? Do you ever hear about the golf trip we went on last year and Jason on our way there, there were like eight of us and Jason's like, okay, here's the deal. Everybody has to put everything out. We're gonna keep score. It's gonna be.
And everybody's like, hey. Aggregate score over four days. And everybody's like, hey man, fucking relax. We haven't even started the trip yet. And he's already wanna take the fun out. Wait, so Rob, okay, we're jumping all over the place. But what I do wanna know is,
when was the move, because you did all these, really successful, great movies, like I pointed out before, Samo's Fire about last night, whatever it was, class, one of my favorite, Masquerade, which I loved as well. Thank you, I like that one. I thought that was a very underappreciated movie.
And then all of a sudden, you start, you made like this switch and you're like, well, I'm gonna do comedies. And all of a sudden you became a guy who was like in every comedy in the 90s, you were in them. And it was a big, was that like a, did you make a conscious decision?
Like, yeah, fuck it, I'm done with this, I'm now gonna do that. How did that happen? I'd loved, always loved comedy. And it was my first love and was obsessed with SNL. I did, for my sixth grade talent show, I did Ackroyd's Basomatic sketch. I loved, loved.
Right? I know that one, Basomatic. Oh yeah, this is the thing where he sells the, Basomatic and he talks really fast and it's crazy. How many times has this happened to you? You have a bass. It wiggles off the hook. Yeah.
And so I hosted SNL and had a really good show and hit it off with Lauren. And I think Lauren saw something in me that nobody had really seen before, that I could really be funny. And then when they, so when they made Wayne's World into a movie. Yes.
I had also connected with Mike on the show. And we sort of just got each other. And so when they were making Wayne's World, they were looking for somebody who had been in a movie. I mean, Mike and Dana, literally, it was just that simple. I think Rob's been in a movie. Sean, tell Tracy who he's talking about really quickly. Oh, what, Mike Myers and Dana Carvey?
There we go. Yeah, Mike Myers and Dana Carvey. Okay. You have to use them sparingly, Rob. You know, you give them the easy ones like that and then you move forward. I know, I got some nervous. No, no, no, Sean.
So you do, so, yeah, of course, of course it's Wayne's World. And that makes sense that you get brought in is not only had you been in a movie, you've been in a lot of big movies and you're a movie star. So for them, it's a great get. And Lauren's like, so you're gonna, Mike's gonna write it and you're doing it, Rob,
and you start tomorrow and you've already said yes and here's your wardrobe and you've said yes and let's go into action. I just, by the way, Will, I just walked with him last week. I hadn't had a good, Lauren Michaels, walked through Beverly Hills in a long time and there were so many great quotes. I really, really, really,
and we have to do a coffee table book. We have to of Lauren quotes. It's, they're the best. One of my favorite, and I love Lauren, I haven't done the walk with him in a few years now, any of the walks. I've done the beach walk. I've done, obviously, the Beverly Hills
flats walk many times. But this is a known thing, that he walks with people? Yeah, like John Sykes said to me the other day, I just did a walk with Lauren and then I saw him with gold. I see he in Goldwyn every time he's in town, John Goldwyn. But I said, he one time, we were talking about the South and he just goes, it's a Mason Dixon line thing. And I was like, oh, I'm sorry, I'm fucking loved.
But Rob, what you did with that comedy turn though, that I sort of felt was, it was just, I just thought it was really admirable that you were doing this, if I remember correctly, at a time when people really were still kind of taking themselves pretty seriously and you were not. And you were assigned a lane too.
Yeah, and you said, yeah, you know what? I'm not gonna bust out of that lane for a lane of, I am a character actor and I'm doing Shakespeare now. He actually went the opposite direction. He said, I'm actually going to kind of make fun of myself a little bit here and just pull my pants down a little bit
and kind of not be quite as gorgeous. It was pretty cool. Yeah, really cool. Well, thanks. I mean, I love it and I still love, you guys know, there's nothing, look, I'm talking to a bunch of guys who get to do, get to play in both pools
and to do, like to be doing Lone Star now and then the show, which is now on Netflix, Unstable with my son, Hard Combat. Oh yeah, you told me about that. That's the fun of it, because they're so different. But when I first got into comedy, when I first got into humor,
you know, when I first decided it was, no one else was in that lane, for sure. No one knew. And also SNL was a thing where like people, like now everybody wants to do it, does it, doesn't think about it. But in those days, like, ooh, you better be careful.
Ooh, I don't know. Like there was all that shit going on. I was like, be careful of what? Right, yeah. But you do Wayne's World, you do Tommy Boy, you do Austin Powers, and then you jump back and you start doing things like, you do a bunch of serious dramas,
you do Brothers and Sisters. West Wing? Well, I was gonna say West Wing, sorry, West Wing first, I was getting to West Wing, but West Wing first, which was a phenomenal show, then Brothers and Sisters with Robbie Bates,
then you go and you make the jump, and then you start doing, I remember the day that Amy's like, I think Rob Lowe's gonna do Parks and Rec, and I was like, what? That's amazing. And all of a sudden, like, you're on a serious drama,
and then the next year you're on a sitcom, and you're on a full-fledged comedy. Yeah, you're an agent's dream. Yeah, very few people get that kind of leeway and can pull it off, and nobody, and there's no part of you that's like, well, he can't do that,
you're like, yeah, well, yeah, it's Rob Lowe, yeah, Rob can do it. Like, that's fucking rad, dude. I mean, you kind of, so for as much as you feel like you're like a lead, you know, a character actor trapped inside a leading man's body, you did what you wanted to do anyway,
which I think is super fucking cool. And still are doing it. And they're still doing it. Yeah. It's pretty rad. And then now you're doing this show with Johnny, who's a great kid, whom I know a little bit.
Yeah, you're signed down, yeah. I mean, Jesus Christ. That's so cool. I remember you saying it, telling me. Talk about this, dude. It's so, it's, I mean, to be able to work with my son,
I mean, it all started with him sort of trolling me on social media, like just brutalizing me. I mean, mercilessly, just for nothing other than to just do it. And people started to notice. And it got to the point that if I was out doing
an interview to promote something, whether it was, you know, the Today show or the Ellen show, it didn't matter what the venue was, all they really wanted to talk about was, your son just loves to make fun of you. And we have some of his greatest hits here. And we were like, Jesus Christ.
So it got to the point where I, we both were like, people really like this. I wonder is there, is there some there there? Cause I mean, literally the audience is saying, we want this, we want more of this.
So we tried to figure out what it would be. And we're like, well, we're not going to do a reality show. And I don't want to do that thing of playing a heightened version of me because Larry David did it so well, it feels kind of done. So what is it?
So we, we've distilled it down to really what it is, is like a larger than life, benevolent narcissist dad, who may or may not be as in touch with the real world as he would like to think. And, and the world just applauds him
and the son who's just like, oh my God, really? And, and so we, we built this show called Unstable. And I play, I play a, you know, like an almost like an Elon Musk tech genius who's unstable on his best days
and maybe insane in his others and John Owen is this, the son who can, is the only one who can speak truth to power. It's, it's super fun. It's called Unstable, by the way. Yes. Yes. It's on Netflix now. It's on Netflix because it's streaming.
Click it. Wow. Go ahead, John. No, I was just going to say that's, I know Tommy Boy so well and I'm such a fan of you in it as everything, but I just love that movie. I think that movie is so beloved by so many people.
Are you guys like, It's amazing, by the way. Sorry, when, when two people start talking at the same time and then somebody goes, no, no, you go ahead. I can't help but say, oh no, I was just going to say,
like I can't stop myself from saying it and I tell myself not to say it. But that's okay. But, but, but you too, like you just said it. It's, it's impossible not to say. Oh no, I was just going to say, right? Yeah, it's like you have to say it as an acknowledgement.
But it's like, it's like yawning when someone else yawns next to you. You can't help it. Anyway, go ahead. Yeah. I was just going to say, Tommy Boy is a movie where, like Wayne's World,
we thought might do, do well. And Austin Powers had that thing. Tommy Boy, we no one ever expected that movie ever to do. And that started with playing tennis was playing tennis with Lauren. I'll never forget it. Lauren, Bernie Brillstein, myself, John Goldblum playing doubles.
Perfect. And Lauren's saying, you know, I think there's something with you and Farley playing brothers. Really? And I was like, wow, that'd be great. And I never heard another thing about it. And then, you know, whatever six months later,
Tommy Boy morphs into what, what it is. But, but I don't think anybody thought, and that's the one that I do think has, you know, who did I just talk to? Oh, Jonah Hill. Yeah. Jonah Hill, and I'm not kidding, will tell you that his favorite movie in the world
is Tommy Boy. Yeah. I'd be pretty close to that. Over Goodfellas, Over the Godvies, I'm telling you, Tommy Boy. It's insane. No, it's one of the greatest comedies of all time. I mean, it's right up there with all of the classics.
No, did Chris make you laugh as much offset as, as on camera? He did. And when you were doing your meek laugh, I thought you were doing Farley. Do your meek laugh, Jason, because it literally is Farley's laugh. That's Farley's laugh.
He killed me. I mean, Chris Farley and Will Farrell, there's just, there's no one funnier than those two guys. I know. To me. No one. Ever. We'll be right back.
SmartLess is brought to you by BetterHelp. Getting to know yourself can be a lifelong process, especially because we're always growing and changing. I mean, just last night alone, my fingernails grew and my hair grew, okay? For just two brief examples. Therapy is all about deepening yourself awareness and understanding because sometimes we don't know
what we want or why we react the way that we do until we talk through things. BetterHelp connects you with a licensed therapist who can take you on that journey of self-discovery from wherever you are. And that's important for a fellow like me that's always on the run, either from police or responsibilities
or I'm running around trying to get paid, you know, working out of town. I mean, I'll do what it takes, guys. And so I just take my laptop with me and my phone and either one of those devices can hook me up to somebody who can help me out with some of the questions that I have about myself. Why do I run from stress?
Or why do I get the runs from stress? Anyway, if you're thinking about starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist. And then, you know, you can also switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge. You just might not be jiving with your talker, you know? That's what I like to call them, fellow talkers. Discover your potential with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today and get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp. I know you need help with this word help,
so I'm gonna spell it for you, H-E-L-P. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P, dot com slash smartlist. Hey listener, we get support from Topgolf. I know it sounds like I'm bragging, but I'm just telling you the facts. Here's more. It's golf, it's not golf, it's Topgolf. Clubs, balls, tees, turf, a ball picker,
upper cart thing, it's all there. But you also get loud music, giant targets in the giant fairway, giant TVs, and a handcrafted food and beverage menu. Put all these things under one roof and you got yourself a good time. So consider this your formal invitation to grab the fam a few friends or some coworkers
and come play around. And I can bring buddies along too to have that same sort of experience. I mean, maybe it'll work for them too, although I have not yet found one person that is as much of a grinder as I am with golf. I got to work on my speed of play. Topgolf helps with that too.
Everyone can play Topgolf, even if no one can swing a club. It's the only place you can play around and then order another or, get it, hit a slice, then grab a slice, get it again. Plus you'll get all the fun of outside but with the comforts of inside, comfy, heated bays in the winter
and cooled bays in the summer. Now, I don't know if I've bored you with this before but I'm a fairly passionate golfer, okay? I like to go out there. Every time I go out and play, I think I'm gonna shoot my record low round. So I'm a real grinder out there. Now, when I went to Topgolf,
it's a different kind of experience. I'm not stressing about my score on 18 holes. I'm just trying to hit quality shots to targets. I'm having fun with friends. So it actually helped my game. Like, it feels different to hit the ball when you're not all bound up because you're worried about your score on the hole.
You know what I mean? I think you know what I mean. So that was my experience. Go check it out. You're gonna love it. Visit topgolf.com slash smartlist to book a bay and come play around. Again, that is topgolf.com slash smartlist.
Our thanks to all birds for their support. Thing about nature is, nature is better than processed. Can I say that? Is that controversial? I don't think it is. We all want stuff that's natural because natural is better.
And when it comes to quality and better, mother nature knows best. And you can take that idea and run with it with wool runners from all birds. Yeah. This year, trade your synthetic footwear for wool runners crafted with premium supernatural materials that are comfy and durable
so you can run to the ends of the earth or the store. I wear the wool runner missiles and they are unbelievable. I just wear them every day. I wear them with everything. And I wear them to when I'm running errands or I wear them if I'm going to meetings, I wear them when I'm at home.
I got these beautiful sort of their navy blue with like a white sole. They look really kind of chic and simple. And they're so unbelievably comfortable. They're really, really light. They form to your foot. Wool runners are built using premium supernatural materials with very low environmental impact.
And they're constantly innovating to increase performance and longevity. So even on your toughest outings, you'll wear out long before your shoes do. And they're machine washable. So they look as fresh as the first day that you got them. And I can attest to that. Mine look very, very fresh.
This year, take a big step forward for mother nature with the all birds wool runner. Discover your perfect pair at allbirds.com today. That's A-L-L-B-I-R-D-S.com. All right, back to the show. So, so you do Tommy boy, you do all this. So then you do talk about West Wing because West Wing was such a,
I mean, that show just, still you can watch it. You can turn it on today and it just completely holds up. It's so good. Isn't that kind of making a research? It's like, I hear people talking about that. I now watch it a lot. Yeah, because politics is such a big part of society now more so than then, I think, right?
It's interesting about West Wing is it kind of comes and goes. It was, people liked it when it was on. And then in the early years of Netflix, the early years, I think it was that and friends where it drove Netflix and then it went off the platform. And now something's going on that they're into it again. I don't know what it is, but I'm hearing a lot about it again too.
I don't know. So Rob, like us, you've been doing the pod, you've been in the podcast space. I like calling it the space. It does sound good. It's good, right? We're in the podcast space. It's better than content.
You should hear me go off about, Rob, I hate when people go, I'm a content creator. So you just make fucking shit. Or storyteller. If you're a storyteller or content provider. Have you liked doing the podcast? Literally with Rob Lowe. I love it.
I have so much fun because I, you know, it's what you guys are just riffing. You're having a good time. You're saying what's on your mind. And sometimes the most trivial stuff is the most fun to talk about. And then you get guests on and a lot of them might have known forever and ever and ever
and know them in a very specific way that no one else is ever gonna know them in the way that I do. So I'm able to bring out sides of them that no one else is gonna be able to do because they don't have the history that I have with them. And, you know, I had Whoopi Goldberg on recently. And I was like, Whoopi, do you remember
when we were on the California Toxic Clean Water Caravan with Michael J. Fox, Jane Fonda, Cher. Just picking up trash down at Santa Monica Pier. And we went through the McDonald's drive-thru. Do you remember, like, where else are you gonna get that? You know what I'm saying? So it's super fun. Rob has got so many unbelievable,
and you're kind of like, and we always hammer Jason and Kimmel loves hammering Jason for stories about, you know, back when he was a teen actor and stuff. You guys have such a long history in this town of doing stuff like that, weird-ass shit, where you're like, yeah, I went on a 10-hour overnight train journey with LaVar Burton. I know.
We were going on our way to Vienna to see the, like, what the fuck? I know, and that Jason went to school with Janet Jackson. It's so crazy. Jason was on the massage bus with Janet Jackson. This is like fucking crazy. That's a whole other thing, Rob. I once saw Rob on a boat in the south of France,
and he comes on and goes, we were just, we just got washed out, right? You got washed out by a flooded river or some shit. Remember that? Yeah, I had survived a flash flood in France. It was like a legit, like real flash flood. Got saved. I was going to be rescued by the police.
Oh, by the way, Jason, we, so I did Jimmy's show, and there's a game that's named after you that they're now renaming after me. I just want you to know. The game. Really? Yes, it's, so it's the game where you put the names in the hat, and then you pull the hat out, and then you have to tell a story about the name.
He pulls a name out of a hat, or some random celebrity from years past, and you have to tell a story associated with it. Oh, I bet Rob, Rob, you must crush that. Oh, you must crush that. I want you and I to play that game. We should go mono a mono. I would give anything to watch you two fucking go on that.
Let's just play a version right now. I'll pick a name for you, and then you pick a name for me. That's a great idea. Okay, ready? That's a great idea. Okay, I'm ready. It's fun. Okay.
Telly Savalas. I don't have any direct interaction with him, but I believe my wife that that my, or no, he may be her godfather, or maybe he's the godfather of Jen Aniston. I think, I... I think he's Jen's godfather, right? I think he's Jen's godfather,
and Amanda and she are so close, so that's why it's... That's pretty good. So it's sort of, it's adjacent too, which reminds me of my new construction company. It's called Adjacent Abatement, and what we do is we go in and we take mold out from... All right, here's my one for you. Pia Zadora.
Mm, yeah, okay. You have one? So I was making out on the Colony Beach with Gregory Peck's daughter. Fucking, oh my God. Fucking it. Everybody shut up, keep going, Rob. And I hear this woman going, that's disgusting.
You should be ashamed of yourself. Don't you have any common decency? There are children on this beach. And I looked up and it was Pia Zadora. That's crazy. But how about for bonus points, we get Gregory Peck's daughter and the Malibu Colony. I mean, Rob, this man is royalty.
You're a hero. Come on. Rob, Jesus Christ, how long have you known Downey? Ninth grade history class. Wow, out there in Malibu? Sam Ohai, Santa Monica High School. Wow. I could see it.
I remember at Christmas when I saw you at the Christmas party and then I saw you talk to Rob and to Downey and I was like, I could immediately see like, oh, this is deep. This is deep, long, deep, deep. You guys have that shorthand of knowing each other since being kids. Yeah.
That was so... And there was no one more fun to party with. Downey made me laugh harder than any human being in the world. And I just love what he's done with his life and he's such an inspiration and a great guy. And by the way, Downey was on the bus with Sharon and Whoopi Goldberg as well.
I mean, he was, we were always doing that stuff. My mom used to call her Whoopi. Well, because in her defense, she couldn't see the whole word because the W was covered. Because that's where the I, the bus. But can't see the bus. And Rob, do you think you'd be able to recall enough
to write a satisfying book? He's written a book. Sorry, let me finish. And he's toward it very successfully. But in a book, when I say book, I mean a follow-up, a series. Yes, yes. What's it called?
Stories I Only Tell My Friends, is that right? Stories I Only Tell My Friends and the follow-up, Love Life. So we were talking about... So I'm talking about the third one. The third one, the third one is called Names and Dates. And it's just Names and Dates and what the fuck has happened? Gregory Peck's daughter, March 12th.
It is Adora, you know, the fucking... So now, Rob, and now you're back. I know that your new thing, well, not new, but you're obsessed with golf. You've been playing a lot. You and I played a couple of months ago with Danny D's, by the way, Rob's good buddies with Danny, who's a friend of the program.
Yeah, he's the best. He's the best. He's the world's only good finance guy. And how you were talking about how obsessed you are with and your game is getting really good. I mean, you're just getting there. You're on it, right? Like you're practicing a lot.
Oh, I practice all the time. I don't get to play as much because I don't have that much time really, but I'm practicing easily four days a week. Like today, I'm at Fox. Is there a goal? Yes, yes. My goal is to do what you did.
I want to play in the AT&T. How was that for you? That was incredible. I mean, we'll almost won the damn thing, but I had a really good time myself too. And all you got to do is just put your hand up. They'll have you up there. I mean...
Rob, you're in. You're in for next year with us. Come on. It was such a blast. It was amazing. I'm doing, guys, I'm doing it. I'm 100% doing it. It always falls right in the middle
of the production schedule, but I'm actually going to ask for the time off next year. And I'm absolutely committing to doing it. There you go. I got to follow Tiger inside the ropes at Genesis. And yeah, I got to be inside the ropes with Tiger, Rory, and JT. It was insane.
Wow. Oh yeah, those rounds were incredible. Were you there the day when Tiger birdied the last three holes and they all birdied 18 together? No, that was the day after. I was there the day that he almost had the hole and won. Yeah.
Oh, that was incredible. Yeah. One revolution. But I also saw him, you know the green with the sand trap in the middle of it? Oh, yeah, totally. You saw him putt into the sand trap. Yes.
Did you see that? I saw Tiger Woods putt into the sand trap, which just to me was the most beautiful thing in the world because I'm like, okay, that's the greatest who ever hoisted a golf club. Yeah, and even he can do that. And even it was the thing was he was going to take his medicine.
He was going to, you know, it's that thing we always do where we can't quite bring ourselves to take our medicine. We kind of also want to do the, he kind of, and he did get up and down before though. He did, but I've putted into that bunker twice. Yep. In my life.
So. I bet he didn't make four. Twice. And the other thing he did that I noticed was whenever he would do something like that, he would go to another gear in whatever the next hole was. Like another gear.
I want to get Tiger on this show. I know, it'd be great to have him on. Me too. I'm wild. God, I just, Rob, I could just listen to you talk about all your stuff, all your. I know, I love. God, it's just everything.
Whether it's his movies or his shows or his life. By the way, well, this is what the podcast is. I mean, because a lot of times somebody will bring up something and I'll go, that reminds me, because I do have a telecivilous story where I was eight years old and Kojak was coming to date in Ohio to sign autographs
from the ladies undergarments of Reich's department store. Oh my God. Is that true? It was, yeah, absolutely true. And so I got my bus fare together. On the graphic underwear on the third floor is Telly Savalas. Yeah, yeah.
And he was probably doing a Kenley Players. It was probably Telly Savalas and, you know, some Arthur Miller show. And I take the bus and I wait in line forever. And I bought him a sucker. Cause I know Telly Savalas likes, remember Kojak always had the sucker? Yeah.
Yeah. He always had up like a Charms blow pop. That was his thing. And so I bought him one and I brought it and I was going to give it to him. And it's a three and a half hour line. And I'm waiting and waiting and waiting and waiting. I finally get right to the front of the line
and they go, that's it. Mr. Savalas has to leave. And he fucking bails. And I'm standing here with my sucker. And I kind of looked for somebody I think is important. And I go, excuse me, would you give Mr. Savalas my sucker? And he goes, oh kid, that's so thoughtful.
I sure will. And I walk away and I'm going down the escalator. I turn around to watch and the guy throws it in the trash can. Oh. That's awful. That actually stayed with me forever. Because whenever, like I meet someone, I'm always like, don't be Telly Savalas.
Don't throw it in the sun, don't be. Right, right, right. And they give you a bag of freshly cooked homemade cookies. And you're like, no, I'm going to eat these. In fairness, it wasn't Telly who did it, it was a guy. It was a handler. It's true. Right, handler.
It wasn't Telly, he probably would have taken it. Telly would have sucked it, for sure. No, he probably would have sucked it. Wait, there's a better way to say it. He's thrown it at you. Well, I wouldn't, I want to listen. I haven't listened, I don't, I'm not really into podcasts, so.
Well, you make a hit podcast. You don't need to listen to another one. I get it. It's a radio show. To Will, he's doing radio. It is radio. It's morning zoo. I feel like it's morning zoo.
Drive time. Yeah, drive time. I'm always, I'm just trying to copy my buddy, Johnny Vaughn over there in the UK. And Rob, you're a helicopter pilot. How's the traffic on the five? Yeah. You know, it's looking a little backed up over here
as the pole would have passed. It's pale lights as far as you can see. We got the uniform for it. Well, Rob, let's get out again. Let's get out and play again. It's really fun. I want to be a part of that as soon as my granddad backheels up.
Yeah, that's not good, man. No, I know. Don't come back too soon. I know. I got a date coming up in two days. I got to have a nice- Are you doing ice baths? You got a date in two days and it made us cool with that? She's just like- She wants me to be smart and safe
and she's letting me make my own decision, which is nice. And so- So she doesn't mind that you're, are you both dating or is it just you? I am icing it. That does seem to help. Good, yeah. I'd tell you one of the nicest thing. And this is a true story.
This is not a bit. I hurt my back a couple of years ago now. And I was at, and I texted J.B. I was like, my back really hurts. Anyway, I was at home and all of a sudden, out of nowhere, into my backyard comes Jason. And he's got like a back heating thing and like an icy hot thing and a bunch of stuff
that he brought for my back. I just dropped it off and then I got back to my hard left. And he came into my backyard. I was in the sauna and he came in and he knocked on me. He's like, I got all this stuff. I was like- Just like a little angel. And then he got back in his car and left. That's right.
Once a year. Yeah. Once, yeah, even a stop clock. I thought even a stopped clock, you know? Tells the right time twice a day. Okay, listen, Rob, we love you, man. I'm so excited about your show with John and he's such a nice kid.
Please say hi to him before me. Yeah. And also say hi to Cheryl. And to Cheryl, your lovely wife of many years. So sweet, God, you guys are such nice peeps and couldn't happen to a better dude. I love you guys. I was so excited.
You're three of my favorite in all series is three of my favorite people. I love everything about you guys. I love hanging with you. I love your work. I love your podcast. Dude, Bateman, you're making me laugh right now. So hard in the fucking trailer for the Air Jordan movie.
I know. It's like only you can fucking steal a trailer with one life. Yeah, I know. It's so great. It's so great. Nice. It's amazing.
It's amazing. It's amazing. Love you, miss you, mean it. Yeah. Love you, miss you, mean it. Santa Barbara will go and hang or in the, let's make it happen. Or just get fired off one of these 10,000 jobs you're doing
and free some time up and let's go hang out. I know. It has to be the weekends. It's not working so hard. All right. It has to be the weekends. Thank you, the great Rob Lowe. We love you, buddy.
I love you. It's low in your chin. It's load. Load. Oh, Rob Lowe. Don't forget, podcast. Rob Lowe, literally. Wherever you get your podcasts.
Literally with Rob Lowe. Listen to Rob's podcast. Listen to Rob's podcast. And unstable on Netflix. You're watching it. You're loving it. Everything Rob Lowe'd all the time. Love you, boys.
Love you, buddy. Thanks for doing this, Rob. Bye, buddy. Bye. Lovely man. That Rob Lowe. That Rob Lowe, he's just always been nice, always been talented, always been handsome.
Yeah. That's another guy I'd like to come back as. I think there's a long list here of guests we've had that I'd like to. Yeah. You can talk to him for hours. We re-encarnated him. We tried to get him on.
I tried to get him on before. He was the one we had technical glitch a couple of weeks ago. And we had to dial. That was Rob. Yes. Oh, that was Rob. Oh, I didn't know. So I've been trying to get him on here forever.
You know, we had a technical glitch with McConaughey way back when, right? When are you going to rebook him? I don't know. I want to get it back on here. That was great. Because when we do have McConaughey on, then we can go through, hopefully we have the recording
of me having my hissy fit. When you had your... Didn't I snap at him a little bit? Didn't I tell him? You did. Your laughing is not making things helpful. Yeah. Surprise guests.
And then you... And then you slammed. Who was laughing? And you slammed your... Yeah, that was so great. And then, and we can talk about contact. And we can talk about contact. You know, but I did, it didn't occur to me.
You're going to fucking break me today, Sean, with the contact change. It occurred to me earlier. Like it is somewhat, it's either dangerous or good or whatever about this thing. Is that we do this all the time. We're always just sort of just, you know, almost every day we're picking up the,
we're talking with one another. No matter what mood we're in, and we drag that into these interviews, these conversations for the public. And oftentimes we're doing this thing in a bad mood. And like, what if we like, what if we get in a fight with one another? I mean, I know it's been, it's been tense a couple of times,
but like, people just get like warts and all on this. And is that smart for us to be doing that? Why not? It's real, it's normal. It's real, I guess, yeah. Also, who cares? Who cares? We're not gonna get in a fight.
Like what's the worst mood number? Fuck you, Sean. Fuck you. Don't you disagree with what I'm sick? We've had, I think it's, I don't know. I just think like who, I really mean it when I say who cares. I mean, we might as well, right?
Cause it's gonna be lights out at some point. And then. Anyway, Rob Lowe, you know- Love Rob Lowe. Love Rob, huh? This Rob Lowe. Hey, you know, Rob was in contact. He was in contact.
He was. He was in contact. And by the way, he's not, he's not allergic to work. Boy, he works a lot. By the way, just for the record, no recollection of him in contact or Matthew McConaughey for that matter. Well, Matthew McConaughey and Johnny Foster
were the stars. Yeah, yeah. But I only remember her in it. And wasn't there a kid too? No? There were no kid. Oh. I'm conflating.
You thinking of Nell? Another Jody Foster vehicle. I do remember the incredible opening pullback, right? From Earth, but all the way back. Oh, and I emailed you that one shot where she runs into the mirror. Into the mirror, yep. How'd they do it?
Still don't know how to do it. Oh, that's how they, that's the kid when she was a little kid. Yes, thank you. Thank you. But wait, but in his show that he's doing now, the 9-1-1 Lone Star, I couldn't tell if he was a cop or a CIA or an F.
B. Y. Right? Go high, go high, go high. We'll allow, and repeat it, and repeat it, and repeat it. I love it. I love it a lot. Smart.
Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barberco. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts,
or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.